Nos dicen que como parte de un experimento
sobre velocidad de trenes,
cuatro distintos conductores midieron la distancia que recorrieron en un cierto intervalo de tiempo
durante un viaje reciente.
Aquí tenemos los 4 trenes, en esta columna el tiempo que les tomó y aquí, la distancia recorrida.
Sin embargo todos ellos usaron distintos intervalos
de tiempo, este cuate uso media hora,
este otro cuate uso 2 horas y están teniendo problemas
al comparar sus datos.
De acuerdo a los datos proporcionados,
¿se movían los cuatro trenes a la misma velocidad durante el experimento?
tenemos que calcular entonces la velocidad
de estos 4 trenes,
basada en la distancia que recorrieron
en este lapso de tiempo.
Para esto recordemos aunque quizás ya lo
sabes, que la distancia es igual a la tasa
de cambio por tiempo, o si dividimos ambos
lados de la ecuación entre tiempo,
tenemos que...
dividimos del lado izquierdo entre tiempo,
del lado derecho entre tiempo estos tiempos
se cancelan y nos queda entonces que la tasa
de cambio es igual a la distancia sobre el tiempo.
Tasa de cambio en este caso es velocidad y
hace sentido, tenemos millas por hora
o metros por segundo o kilómetros por hora, la tasa
de cambio que en este caso es velocidad,
es distancia dividida entre tiempo.
Usando esto dividimos la distancia recorrida
entre el tiempo empleado para cada tren
y así calcular su velocidad.
Hagamos eso entonces, calculemos la velocidad.
Voy a poner aquí otra columna para incluir
la velocidad...
Velocidad...
Ahí la tenemos.
Entonces, para este amigo, recorrió 27.5
millas en .5 horas, calculemos su velocidad,
es distancia que es 27.5 millas dividido entre
.5 horas, hagamos esta división.
Esto es lo mismo que 27.5 por 2...
déjame ponerlo de la siguiente manera...
27.5 por 2 y 27.5 por 2 es igual a 55...
55 y esta velocidad está en millas por hora.
En este caso, la velocidad es de 55 millas por hora.
Ahora, para este amigo es bastante directo,
recorrió 55 millas en 1 hora,
velocidad es distancia entre tiempo, por lo cual la velocidad es 55 millas por hora...
55 millas por hora...
Lo podemos poner en la fórmula, 55 es la
distancia, 1 es el tiempo,
55 entre 1 es 55 millas por hora.
El siguiente conductor recorrió 82.5 millas en 1.5 horas,
¿cuánto nos da eso?
82.5 millas en 1.5 horas, calculemos eso...
voy a tener que hacer la división larga
para calcular esto.
Dividamos entonces entre 1.5, 82.5, multiplicando
por 10 ambos números
o recorriendo el punto decimal a la
derecha, es lo mismo.
Recorro el punto decimal aquí y también
lo recorro acá.
Tenemos que dividir 825 entre 15.
Empecemos, 82 entre 15, 15 por 6 es 90, 82
entre 15 es 5, 5 por 5 = 25 llevamos 2,
5 por 1 = 5 y 2 = 75, restemos 75, 82 menos
75 nos da 7, bajamos el 5 que tenemos acá,
75 entre 15, como ya vimos, esto es igual a 5,
5 por 15 = 75, 75 menos 75 es 0,
entonces la velocidad de este amigo es
también 55 millas por hora.
Y finalmente si recorres 110 millas en 2 horas,
110 dividido entre 2 es 55 millas por hora.
Así es que al final de cuentas, todos los conductores viajaron a la misma velocidad de 55 millas por hora.